estamos en la población de slobians que
la provincia de dones muy cerca de los
frentes del imán y de bacmut donde las
autoridades ucranianas aseguran que las
últimas horas Han detenido al menos 38
ataques de las fuerzas rusas que en esta
parte del frente en el este del país
especialmente hacia el norte en los
límites con la provincia de harquive
intentan avanzar y romper las líneas
defensivas de los ucranianos que
aseguran que han logrado detenerlos esto
sucede en un momento en el que el
presidente boludo
anoche al lo que sucedía en estos
frentes de batalla no solamente en el
don sino también en saporilla Y decía
que ayer había sido un gran día que
habían logrado avanzar en todos los
franceses y que esperaba que esto
siguiera siendo así esto sucedía en un
momento en que la había visitado esta
región muy cerca donde nos encontramos
había estado con algunos de los soldados
que pelean en el frente se tomó un café
con ellos en una gasolinera y él les
decía que esperaban que este momento en
el que las fuerzas ucranianas van hacia
adelante continuará días atrás había
dicho que esta contraofensiva que en
este momento libran las fuerzas de kiev
no se podía ver como una película de
Hollywood las noticias que se han tenido
es que han logrado romper algunas
defensas en la en el frente de saporilla
especialmente camino hacia mariopol y
melitopol dos de esas grandes ciudades
que están en control de las fuerzas
rusas y que esperan ser recuperadas por
las fuerzas de kiev pero la gran noticia
para los ucranianos es que han
recuperado una población dentro de la
provincia de dones que estaban control
de las fuerzas rusas desde 2014 esta
sería la primera población que está hace
más de nueve años sin control de los
rusos que vuelve a ser recuperada por el
gobierno de kiev que asegura como decía
anteriormente que siguen avanzando en
estos frentes que la situación es
complicada aquí se oyen
explosiones pero sin embargo llegan
buenas noticias especialmente también
aquí en el donbadas desde el frente de
backmud donde siguen avanzando y
recuperando A los alrededores de la
ciudad